ces enjeux d'abordabilité d'accès au
logement ainsi que des pistes de
solutions seront abordés lors du sommet
sur l'habitation organisé par la
mairesse de longueuil catherine fournier
et le maire de laval stéphane boyer le
26 août prochain on les reçoit tous les
deux en studio ce soir merci d'être là
alors on entendait dans le reportage qui
précédé votre arrivée le fait que la
construction la rénovation de 6000
logements sociaux à montréal la mairesse
des s'est pris en otage par une
mésentente entre québec et ottawa quelle
est votre lecture de l'arrimage des
différents paliers gouvernementaux le
camp tes questions de logement sociaux
monsieur boyer d'abord oui je voudrais
l'habitation deux volets un volet
subventionnés dont il logements sociaux
ou en effet il ya plusieurs problèmes
donc souvent les programmes sont
sous-financés son complexe trop long à
mettre en oeuvre et il ya souvent un
manque d'arrimage entre les sommes
possible en fait disponible à ottawa et
les approbations à québec donc ça c'est
un gros enjeu personnes l'autre volet
c'est tout cas si l'habitation pour
monsieur tout le monde qui n'est pas
subventionné mais qui vit aussi une
crise concernant les logements sociaux
madame fournier on a souvent de belles
promesses on nous en promettent des
milliers mais il ya un décalage entre le
moment de la promesse et la réalisation
ça peut être très long et quand ça va
vraiment de l'avant est-ce que quelles
sont les pistes de solution là que vous
aimeriez explorées lors de votre sommeil
au mois d'août c'est également une
question de semaines on va annoncer des
gros chiffres mais quand on regarde ce
que ça donne dans une saleté comme
longuet l'année dernière on a eu droit
par exemple à 9 millions de dollars on a
pu financer 70 unités c'est sûr qu'il
fait bien mais les besoins sont bien
plus grand en ce moment je chez nous on
a 1000 unités le prêtre qui ont un
terrain qu'on pourrait développer dès
maintenant mais où on manque de
financement lorsque c'est sûr que comme
hervé stephan c'est une partie des
revendications c'est une revendication
ses traditionnelles du monde nous parle
qu'on veut réitérer lors du sommet sur
l'habitation veut également pouvoir
explorer toutes sortes de pistes sortir
des sentiers battus pistes et
responsabilités aussi en tant que
municipalité parce que oui à une
question des financements pour le
logement social mais quand on parle
d'habitation il faut également regarder
tous les leviers france ils sont à notre
disposition les leviers également
réglementaire est ce qu'on peut
accélérer les mises en chantier qu'on
peut accompagner autant les développeurs
communautaire pour le logement social et
abordable mais également les promoteurs
privés pour les logements plus hauts
standards et qu'on puisse justement
accéléré parce qu'en ce moment la crise
et est attribuable à un débalancement
important entre l'offre et la demande de
logements lorsque vous dites madame
fourni que vous pouvez en faire plus
c'est ce que c'est que vous prenez une
partie du blâme si vous voulez monsieur
voyez ce que vous reconnaissez que les
municipalités pourraient faire avancer
les dossiers plus rapidement pour
freiner oui à la fois la hausse des
loyers mais la hausse des prix des
habitations en général je pense que
c'est une responsabilité commune qu'on a
et peut-être que traditionnellement les
villes ont demandé on se limiter à
demander plus d'argent de québec
d'ottawa mais je crois que ça doit aller
plus loin si on doit faire
d'introspection nous lever l'on doit
s'assurer par exemple d'être agile
piratés dames et relais permis de
construction on peut avoir des normes
esthétiques environnementales élevées
mais ça veut pas dire pour autant que
nos processus doit va être long et
complexe donc pour moi c'est pas juste
une question de faire des demandes à
québec et ottawa c'est aussi une
question de se regarder dans un miroir
de dire à qui nous comme une station du
parc est ce qu'on peut faire de mieux et
si entre autres pour ça qu'on avance et
initiatives du sommet pour sortir un
petit peu d'aidé des demandes le
conventionnel qu'on fait évidemment voix
l'erythrée passait vraiment de l'argent
c'est vrai que fo québec puis à savoir
se parlent mais faut aller plus loin que
ça faut trouver des nouveaux de modèles
d'affaires faut trouver des nouveaux
outils réglementaires légaux les villes
on doit améliorer nos processus donc
c'est vraiment le prendre c'est la plus
grande dépense que les ménages vivent et
donc pour moi c'est un enjeu fondamental
il ya pas de dépôts de petites mesures
il va falloir faire tout ce qu'on peut
faire en hiver à notre niveau et au
niveau des autres failli c'est clair
qu'il faut mettre les bouchées doubles
que ce soit pour les logements pour en
fait pour les loyers pour les
habitations à l'achat la pch qui dit
récemment il manque 100 mille logements
la schl 10 fois en construire trois
millions cinq cent mille à l'échelle du
canada parce qu'il ya un manque cruel
d'habitation en ce moment est-ce que
vous pensez que ces chiffres là madame
fournis sont exagérées ou vous la sentez
vous le sentez ce manque important sur
votre territoire annonce tant l'ampleur
du défi le pied bien sûr on a commencé à
avoir cette problématique le se poindre
le bout du nez l'avantagé à montréal à
longueuil et laval dans les dernières
années le ça commence avec survie puis
maintenant c'est partout au québec qu'en
parlant nos collègues qui on voit les
chiffres on voit les augmentations le
tout à l'heure on voyait les prix et des
loyers qui ont qui ont vraiment explosé
un peu partout à travers à travers le
québec à travers les territoires donc
c'est un problème qui est généralisé que
les défis de l'habitation sont complexes
comment est ce que justement on accélère
les mises en chantier l'accès à la
propriété avec la hausse des taux
d'intérêt qui est attendu plus on vient
vivre des années de surchauffe
immobilière
alors comment est-ce qu'on veut
justement pouvoir accompagner les jeunes
familles à pouvoir se trouver se trouver
un logement c'est certain que pour nous
comme ils eussent été très préoccupante
parce que quand vous parlez de jeunes
familles c'est sûr on fait face à une
barrière qui de plus en plus haute avec
les coûts de l'habitation est entre
autres dans des études de publier dans
les derniers jours on semblait
comprendre que les prix augmentent
peut-être même plus rapidement dans les
banlieues même jusqu'aux campagne
comment ça se passe du côté de l'ama je
crois que les prix augmentent même plus
rapidement qu'à montréal en ce moment
oui mais ce qu'on a vu avec la pandémie
c'est que beaucoup de gens ont tenté
d'avoir des logements plus grands parce
qu'ils devaient travailler à domicile on
vivait en famille ont cherché notre
bulle privée donc ya beaucoup de gens
qui ont quitté les plus petits logements
prévoir des plus grands donc en effet on
ce qu'on voit c'est une hausse marquée
des prix dans le cas dans la zone à
laval le prix de l'accès à popeater
augmenté de 66%
le prix des loyers de 30% les
différentes façons de mesurer mais dans
tous les cas ça reste des hausses
considérables c'est du jamais vu depuis
plusieurs décennies on voit justement à
l'écran les prix le lancement de la
province pour un loyer 1300 $ par mois
en hausse de 9% depuis un an à montréal
7 % d'augmentation et c'est encore plus
effectivement dans les banlieues
gouvernement du québec dit une des
solutions passe aussi par la
densification que ce soit pour les
grandes où les plus petites villes est
ce que c'est une solution à laquelle
vous attacher beaucoup d'importance à
madame fournit tout à fait en fait c'est
la seule façon de répondre à la fois à
la crise du logement mais également à
l'autre grand crises auxquelles nous
faisons face la crise climatique donc
par exemple laval et longueuil sont deux
villes fortement urbanisées où il
demeure certain milieu naturel qui
pourrait être tentant de vouloir
développer pour faire du logement on
peut pas faire c'est reparti au mieux
nassr elles nous rendent des services
écologiques importants nous on a comme
responsabilité en tant que des stars
politiques en 2022 devenir protéger ces
milieux naturels mais en même temps il
faut qu'on puisse augmenter l'offre de
logements donc trouvons des solutions et
ça passe par la densification
nécessairement ceux ci de l'année
situation puis ciel réitéré ce n'est pas
seulement les tours à condos bien sûr il
ya des secteurs qui peuvent le permettre
comme chez nous dans le secteur du métro
on va pouvoir développer davantage en
hauteur mais d'adam situation de 12 à
échelle humaine s'est assis dans les
quartiers résidentiels qu'on parle de
réglementation qui pourrait faciliter le
développement de logements sont des
territoires on peut parler du fait que
les villes devraient assouplir leurs
règles pour permettre le multi logements
la transformation de maisons
unifamiliales en de logement par exemple
ou encore faciliter le multi
générationnel qu'on voit également dans
certaines parties du québec qui innovent
ou même à l'international c'est de
permettre et la construction d'unités de
maison accessoires tous les plus grands
pères ait présenté dans le west à
vancouver en trading mais c'était
intéressant donc c'est des solutions
dont on veut traiter lentilles semaine
habitations de voir vraiment les
résultats tangibles par la suite ce sera
aux villes de justement s'approprier les
solutions pi des testé sur nos
territoires selon les réalités propres à
chaque ville qui sont polis même dans
les grandes villes comme longueuil laval
qui n'en est plus petit terminal réagi
lors de tout ça on estime que dans le
grand montréal en dix prochaines années
ces trois cent trente mille personnes
supplémentaires qui vont s'implanter
donc on a un choix à faire si on
considère le pib comme le faisait
autrefois ils recrutent agricole y
aurait plus de base et donc on n'a pas
le choix de repenser comment on
développe nos villes puis après c'est la
densification mais ça veut pas dire
forcément tours à condos ça peut être
juste d'avoir des ensembles plus dans sa
patte de redévelopper des grands centres
d'achat donc plein de façons de le faire
je crois que la discussion qu'on doit
avoir des bottes stick on doit avoir
c'est justement comment repenser comment
on développe les villes
protéger ce qui nous reste deux milieux
naturels alors en terminant sommet qui
aura lieu donc à peu près un mois avant
la tenue des élections saint nazaire ou
1er septembre et on va le dire parce
qu'on va quand même repérer certaines
demandes mais c'est l'aboutissement
stéphane et moi on avait pris
l'engagement durant la dernière campagne
électorale municipale de tenir le sommet
fut d'ailleurs qui est quand même
encourageant la danse c'est que tout le
monde a levé la main autant le
gouvernement du québec le gouvernement
fédéral et les autres grandes villes qui
seront présentes au sommet des
promoteurs privés des organismes va y
avoir plus de 300 invités on va le web
diffusé parce qu'il ya énormément de
membres donc les gens ont envie de
prendre part à à la solution donc tant
mieux si québec embarque dans la foulée
parfait mais je vous remercie à tous les
deux d'être passé ne soient pas
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]